le pont Jacques Gabriel celui qui
enjambe la Loire en centre ville de
Blois désormais c'est géant regardé deux
colosses de 9 mètres de haut imaginé par
la compagnie Louxor il s'illumine dès ce
soir et jusqu'au 1er janvier objectif
sensibiliser aux enjeux environnementaux
et à la fragilité des constructions
humaines
d'Aurélie Renaud
pour un géant il faut sortir les gros
moyens seul une grue peut soulever les
500 kg de fibres de verre avec ces 9
mètres le colosse ne laisse pas les
Blaise indifférents
bah oui ça donne envie de découvrir ce
soir quand ça sera quand ça sera monté
je reviendrai faire un tour je pense et
ben ouais c'est sympa ça ça permettra
d'avoir une belle vue du pont et comme
ça tout le monde pourra bien admirer
Blois au final de géant seront installés
sur le pont Jacques Gabriel les colosses
seront un rempart à la puissance de la
loi une scénographie imaginée par la
compagnie Louxor
les colosses représentent l'humanité
l'humanité qui construit les ponts mais
qui est quand même un petit peu en
danger avec tout ce qui se passe autour
de des réchauffement climatiques des
problèmes de transition écologique etc
donc ils viennent soutenir le pont en
cas de crue c'est un projet qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
sensibilisation au risque de cru en
quelque sorte
créer en 2019 ce projet a déjà été
installé sur le Rhône sur la zone ou
encore l'Allier une initiative qui
divise parfois les passants
ça c'est pas beau je suis désolé mais
c'est du plastique en plus un message
qui est pas forcément très cohérent bah
eux c'est sûr qu'on a vu la loi qui a
monté déjà plusieurs fois il y a eu des
crues des choses comme ça donc oui
c'est intéressant pour le l'écologie
ouais
les colosses de la Loire seront Tamaris
au pied de deux piles du pont Jacques
Gabriel jusqu'au 1er janvier 2023